jeune soldat russe est donc accusé
d'avoir tué un civil ukrainien il ne
serait pas le seul d'autres cas
d'exactions sont recensés autour de la
capitale bonjour cyril payen vous êtes
sur place avec mohamed farhat pour
france 24 vous avez recueilli des
témoignages de plusieurs civils
ukrainien
oui effectivement alors qu'on parle
effectivement aujourd'hui de ce premier
crime de guerre de cette première
condamnation ce qui d'ailleurs dans le
calendrier est assez inédit il est assez
rare effectivement des pays jugent alors
qu'ils sont encore en guerre pour les
premiers les premiers justiciables et
bien c'est il est vrai qu aujourd'hui
c'est certainement une partie de cet
iceberg géant de ces exactions de masse
qui ont été commises et qui sont encore
commises là où les combats font rage et
bien avant on pense au donbass à la
crimée à la pièce et au sud est de
l'ukraine où il ya de l'eau une
occupation militaire russe et donc mais
nous avons pu effectivement pas
rencontré de ces dernières 48 heures
avec mohammad farhad à la frontière de
la biélorussie à l'ouest de la capitale
kiev où nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
c'est à dire des villages des régions
entières qui ont été ceux occupation
militaire russe par des régiments russe
au moment du début de la guerre quand te
sers en jus et ses régiments ont fondu
via la biélorussie sur la capitale kiev
pour tenter de l'assiégé enquête
toujours là les témoignages sont
évidemment à la fois effrayante glaçant
et on sent que ce n'est que le début et
bien d un travail d les enquêteurs ces
témoignages c'est très simple il s'agit
de viol pour la plupart des centaines de
femmes qui auraient été violées par des
successions de régiments militaires
russes qui s'installait dans les
villages et des exactions aussi des
viols qui implique des jeunes hommes des
disparitions également comme ce que nous
disent la dila de la population locale
des trophées je les cite des trophées
avec des disparitions de jeunes garçons
dont on ne sait pas aujourd'hui où ils
ont été emmenés donc absolument des
témoignages de d'horreur absolue qui
donne un aperçu le voile sur ces
semaines d'occupation alors que l'armée
russe tentait de prendre dans la
capitale kiev ya eu la seconde vague
vers le lot place de 2,2 par kiev car
qui paient aussi dans les villages ont
été occupés on sait qu'il ya une
contre-offensive ukrainienne et que ces
villages sont en train d'être libéré et
là aussi ce sont ce même genre de
témoignage absolument effroyable et
l'histoire sur doute on retiendra cette
responsabilité de l'armée russe sur le
terrain ces témoignages effroyable qui
émane des survivants de co2 occupée par
les russes cyril cela fait trois mois
que la guerre a commencé ça fera trois
mois demain exactement est ce qu'on peut
en tirer les premiers enseignements
mais côté le premier enseignement c'est
que vous pouvez certainement le voir
nous sommes dans le centre de kiev kiev
il ya deux mois là où nous étions était
sous loi martiale il n'y avait personne
dans les rues a pas des bunkers des
checkpoint et des hommes militarisé des
hommes et des femmes militarisée et
partout ici c'est un sentiment
incroyable de résistance qui a pris tout
le monde par surprise et a compris
évidemment l'état major russe et bien
c'est transformé en sentiments de
résilience puisque ici c'est de la
résidence la vie est extrêmement
compliqué le pays est en guerre mais
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine et kiev qui
donc finalement n'a pas été pris grâce à
la résistance farouche des villes de ce
tome elle dira pedneault deux bouts de
chalets ville résidentielle qui se
trouve à l'ouest là où je me trouve bien
les gens et tente de revivre cette la
résidence est la forme nous distille de
résister à cette occupation et à cette
invasion militaire russe pour autant on
est certainement la croisée de chemin
puisque personne ni les russes ni les
ukrainiens n'ont véritablement perdu
mais pas plus gagné la guerre et
aujourd'hui ce que pensent beaucoup les
et craignait on a vu parler à des
officiels ici c'est l'appui de
l'occident la pluie des nations
étrangères de la communauté
internationale on sait qu'il y a des
nations qui s'engage qui essayent
militairement d'aidé pour que les
ukrainiens puisse en découdre avec
l'armée russe mais comme le déplorent
certains officiels ici et il faut le
dire très franchement aussi une grande
partie de la population il déplore que
certaines nations et c'est vrai que la
france est souvent pointée du doigt
d'après ce des dernières déclarations
des dernières semaines notamment par la
voix du président français emmanuel
macron et bien tente toujours de
organiser des mini nations tentent
toujours de parler à vladimir poutine
qui est pour tout le monde ici l'homme à
battre que la guerre ne cessera que
quand il aura cessé d'être pouvoir en
russie merci beaucoup cyril payet envoyé
spécial france 24 à kiev avec mohamed
farhat